so what is happening this season
well it was very interesting because you
know we're doing this well you know
you're doing it post covet yeah so you
know what was it going to be like so
there was a whole logistical issue
but what was amazing that pretty much
everyone who came on on the show this
year came with a really really positive
kind of like attitude you know it was
almost like yeah we've gone through like
a really really bad year yeah but we're
coming on the show because we want to
change our lives yeah blah blah blah
blah blah i want to get out of our house
exactly yeah and actually a lot of
people weirdly they we're not weird
actually it's logical when you think
about it they actually developed these
acts while they were in lockdown they
weren't all great by the way but it was
interesting how they used their time
yeah so i found it fascinating i love
that they were productive yeah
there were some amazing stories you're
going to see kelly and then there are
some very wacky acts uh but i like that
combination what i like about the show
is you just never know
what they're gonna do until they walk
out i think that's why it's massively
popular just that unknown yeah and
nothing is like predictable i love that
sitting there watching it that is what
you feel as well yeah um but what are
your what are your favorite and least
favorite acts like i imagine you love
the singers right oh yeah i love the
singers um
i think the hardest act uh when you're
doing auditions is when a comedian goes
wrong because when a comedian goes wrong
it i mean it feels like it's going on
for like hours yeah it's horrific and
you feel bad for them yeah and there's
nothing you can say literally like if a
singer goes wrong you can tell if you've
got a second song whatever when a
comedian goes wrong it's deadly and oh
yeah what do you say you can't wow
there's nothing there's just like total
silence so there's nothing you can do
about it um
so those are those are the hardest ones
um but like we said i love the
unpredictability i my personal favorites
are people who aren't professionals they
have like you know like regular jobs
yeah they've always dreamt about doing
something and they develop this
incredible talent those are my favorite
auditions yeah my favorite two are the
ones that like you see people come out
like a woman that does whatever job and
you're like so okay and you're like so
like why are you here and then like all
of a sudden they like blow you away it's
that moment of like they just didn't
they never got their shot they never had
the opportunity to like show what they
could do i love that
and can let me ask you a question so
when you're judging
your show now i mean how do you find it
being on the other side now
i'm
i feel like i'm a good mix of you and
paula i feel like i'm because i'm a
cheerleader i'm a cheerleader in the
sense and i'm very good i gotta tell you
well no well i'm i'm i feel like i try
to be but i think i'm a mix of both of
you because i am very honest but i try
and be constructive with it but what was
so interesting about you and i always
remember this with you is that you
always knew
who where you wanted to be after the
show
you know the kind of artist you wanted
to be you didn't need anyone to give you
that kind of guidance i mean it was like
i think about it now no because i like
doing lots of different styles so that
was hard
no it's like i use you as an example a
lot i genuinely mean this you're one of
the nicest people
i've ever met most loyal i can say that
because we've known each other a long
time but if i if people have to say you
know what advice can you give me i just
say
follow kelly
oh my gosh that's true yeah
[Music]